when we're talking about being in
Guantanamo Bay a lot of the stories that
have come out from there and there's
been whole documentaries made out about
the the horrific torture that went on in
there did you see any of that were you
witness to any of them we didn't see it
physically with our eyes
um but we are I experienced it myself
and obviously when you're in
um in Camp
um when you're in your interrogation
room or the booth you can hear the
person next to you getting tortured and
you're walking down the i o you can hear
screams from each room but physically
seeing it was always closed off and you
say you experienced it yourself so what
did you so like for example the only
thing that I didn't do with me was the
waterboarding